so this is exciting I just happen to see
that the band Green Day is writing a
book apparently you may remember Green
Day from the nineties they're apparently
writing a book called the last of the
American girls and it's supposed to be
an homage and handbook for women how do
you think that's gonna go over a
handbook for women
written by dudes how do you think people
are gonna respond it why would a
publisher sign off on an idea like that
in the in this day and age but if if
publishers will sign off on that then
perhaps I too will also write a handbook
for women and I expect it to be received
very well it would just be you know it
would just be a book of advice and
instructions guidelines for women that's
all from me and I think feminists would
would find it very useful I suspect so
be on the lookout for that all right a
bunch of speaking of feminist a bunch of
Hollywood actors are having a humongous
hissy fit because of the bill in Georgia
that would ban abortions once a
heartbeat is detected and the bill has
not been signed yet but these actors are
all pledging to boycott the state great
great chat tragedy for Georgia if they
lose these these people Mark Hamill and
Natalie Portman are the latest actors to
sign off on it and I am being very
generous to Mark Hamill by calling him
an actor because honestly I in fact just
recently I tried to I've never been a
I've never been a Star Wars fan myself
and I'm not just saying that now because
Mark Hamill is a pro-abortion wacko
although he is and he's always been that
but I've never been a big star Wars fan
I don't see the big deal with with the
whole series McKay I don't see it as
some groundbreaking thing that should
elicit religious fervor out of us but I
tried recently to go back and give it
another shot and I said I'm gonna you
know everyone loves Star Wars I must be
missing something I tried to go back and
watch
the original movies and my lord I mean
the acting is so terrible especially on
mark Hamill's Part III kid it's
unwatchable to me I don't know how
people do it I guess you had to watch it
for the first time I guess when you were
very young so you so that this sort of
affection grows for it and and so now
you have that nostalgia which causes you
to overlook just how absolutely terrible
the acting and the writing is it pretty
much all of these movies anyway that's
beside the point
so Mark Hamill and Natalie Portman are
the latest to join the protest Ben
Stiller also is protesting Debra Messing
Minnie Driver Alec Baldwin Amy Schumer
Rosie O'Donnell Sean Penn brie Larson
Patricia Arquette a literal murderers
row of people whose opinion I couldn't
care less about
speaking of although I gotta say I mean
when I found out you know that Debra
Messing is is is against this bill it
really made me for a minute I don't know
about these other people but for a
minute I really did have to rethink my
entire position on abortion I mean
because if Debra Messing this is Debra
Messing we're talking about star of uh
you know some shows I you know she's a
great huge star of a lot of different I
didn't if she doesn't if she's in favor
of abortion then there must be something
to it right so you've got all these
people but maybe the most irrelevant
voice of all is that of Alyssa Milano
who is heading this backlash against
Georgia and she tweeted something a
couple of days ago trying to find
spiritual religious justification it
would seem for her quest to ensure that
babies with heartbeats are still
murdered and I'll show you her tweet
this is what she said I love God I
believe in God but I don't believe my
personal beliefs of which we can't
confirm should override scientific facts
and what we can confirm and then she
quotes John 3:12
if I have told you earthly things and
you do not believe how can you believe
if I tell you heavenly things okay I'm
trying to decipher this is she implying
that abortion is a heavenly thing is
that I think that's what's going on here
so this is pure pure Satanism of course
which I'm not surprised to hear that
coming from a pro-abortion Hollywood
actress but even so I don't need I don't
get because it seems that her personal
belief is that abortion is good right so
she says personal beliefs can't override
scientific facts I agree with that so
her personal belief in the validity of
abortion and the legit moral legitimacy
of it can't override scientific facts I
agree there but I don't think she's
trying to say that I think she's trying
to say that personal beliefs about the
immorality of abortion should not
override scientific facts so is she
saying that her personal beliefs are
opposed to abortion I don't know but
let's not get hung up on particulars I
just want to use this tweet as a
jumping-off point because this you hear
this kind of stuff all the time and
there are two big problems here aside
from the from the general incoherence of
of it but there's two other problems
first okay opposition to abortion is not
simply a personal belief and it
certainly is not a religious belief okay
and this and this frustrates me to no
end with the people that so that's just
your religion you're just saying that
because you're a Christian even if I
were not a Christian even if I were not
religious at all even if I had no faith
I would still oppose abortion because
it's the murder of babies and and
there's nothing there's no scenario
where I would ever be in favor of that I
didn't learn in the Bible that abortion
is wrong I didn't I I didn't have to
check the Bible to find out whether or
not abortion is wrong I came to that
conclusion without heat without checking
it at all I just I just know that it's
wrong it doesn't so it's it's
don't need to find chapter and verse for
that I can find chapter and verse I can
find biblical justification certainly
for my belief that abortion is wrong but
even if I couldn't I would still believe
it even if there was nothing in the
Bible for instance saying don't kill
people don't murder there is but even if
there wasn't I would still be against it
so this is not a religious point of view
I cannot emphasize that enough and I get
really tired of this whole well stop
trying to impose your religion on me
thing when it comes to abortion because
you may as well say that I'm forcing my
religion on you by opposing armed
robbery and arson and rape these are
fundamental moral issues and any person
religious or not is capable of seeing
the truth in these matters
moreover pro-abortion people also like
to claim that the Bible doesn't even
really say anything about abortion in
the first place and and they're right in
a way the Bible doesn't specifically
mention abortion it does mention not to
murder people which which which really
covers that base anyway so it doesn't
need to be specific about you know if it
says don't murder people then you
wouldn't think that it needs to also
specify yeah by the way that includes
babies so but it doesn't it's true that
it doesn't deal specifically with the
practice of abortion so there's kind of
it's the pro-abortion people are trying
to have it both ways we're on one hand
they they say you're imposing your
religion on us and then on the other
hand they say well that's not even
really in your religion well then which
is it it can't decamp we can't be
imposing our religion on you with
something that isn't in our religion
according to you because in that case if
that were true that our our pro-life
beliefs are not really in keeping with
the Bible then that would mean that we
are imposing our moral opinion on to the
Bible and
and according to you on to you but it
wouldn't be our religion then in that
case would it now again that's not true
this this belief is entirely consistent
not only consistent with what the Bible
says but it is in the Bible because it
says do not murder but you're trying to
have it both ways you know the
pro-abortion people when it comes to
their arguments that they make they're
constantly making conjured self
contradictory arguments with no attempt
to even come up with some sort of
coherent cogent narrative and then the
second thing here is that of course
putting the issue of religion to the
side entirely for a minute science is
completely and totally on the side of
pro lifers and there's just no question
about that whatsoever and in fact the
more and more that we learn about
science the more that we learn about
what's happening in the womb the more
that we learn about the development of
human beings in the womb the more and
more validity it lends to the pro-life
side the the pro-abortion side has
always been morally untenable but it was
much more tenable 50 or 60 years ago
than it is now because we knew a lot
less 50 or 60 years ago than we do now
we still knew enough 50 or 60 years ago
we knew enough 500 yeah we knew enough
5,000 years ago to know that abortion is
wrong because you're killing a human
person because what else could it be
when I when a human man and a human
woman get together and reproduce the
only thing they can produce is a human
and that human is going to by definition
be separate and apart from themselves
but as I said the more that we've
learned just the more credibility it
lends to the pro-life case and so if
you're a pro-abortion person that ought
to make you uncomfortable when you look
and realize that I mean gee every single
scientific discovery in this area
every single scientific advancement in
this area goes against us well that
should tell you that something is wrong
with your position all right so I
thought this was interesting from the
daily wire it says a small School
District in Michigan is pushing back
against those who would alter its sex ed
program by incorporating discussions of
sexual and gender identity for the last
eight years Allendale Michigan a town of
roughly 26,000 people has offered a sex
ed program titled willing to wait which
holds fast to the benefits of abstaining
from sex until marriage and does not
address the issues of gender and gender
identity but you've got the progressive
indoctrinate errs who now want to
introduce that stuff into the program
and so there's that whole debate and
this brings up the the safe sex first
abstinence debate and I know that this
is where you probably think I'm gonna
launch into a whole thing where I defend
abstinence only programs but maybe I'm
gonna surprise you because I'm not gonna
do that I won't defend I'm not gonna
defend abstinence only programs I'm also
not going to defense safe sex programs
because here's my point when it comes to
sex ed in schools
I don't want teachers talking to kids
about using condoms and so on that's not
an appropriate discussion for that forum
I also don't want teachers talking to
kids about saving sex for marriage I
don't want either of those things
neither of those things are an
appropriate discussion for for a
classroom I I want them saying nothing
on the matter at all that's how sex ed
should be handled talk to kids about
biology talked to them about Anatomy
about human reproduction these are
academic subjects and it's stuff that
kids need to learn at a certain age so
yeah they're going to learn about sex in
that sense but I don't need school
officials giving any lessons any advice
at all one way or another about about a
child's sex life or lack thereof because
it's none of their business but why have
we just taken it for granted that well
the school's got to say something about
this I mean the kids are there for a few
hours a day I mean they got to talk to
him about sex don't they why why do they
need to talk just stick with the stick
with the academic subjects
I don't need your moralizing one way or
another I don't need your theories about
when people should have sex and how they
should do it and what's the appropriate
context I don't need that whether you
think it's appropriate for teenagers to
have sex or whether you think that
should save it for marriage why do you
think that it's your place as a teacher
in a school to talk to my kids about it
it's none of your business
so say nothing about it that's that's
the solution here I so know I'm not a
fan of the absent abstinence programs in
school because I don't trust schools to
make the case for abstinence that is a
very morally complex issue and it is a
moral issue now there's a practical
element to it also of course we're okay
if you don't have sex right now then
you're not gonna get STDs and you're not
gonna get pregnant so fine yeah there's
that practical but but you can't try to
simply scare kids away from sex that
doesn't work so if you try to have an
abstinence program that doesn't get into
the morality aspect but it only focuses
on STDs and everything well that's just
not gonna work because then you're just
trying to scare kids by saying oh well
you know you don't want to herpes do you
doesn't work and and it's also I'm not
trying to we don't want to make people
terrified of sex we don't want them to
make this immediate where they think of
sex they immediately associate it with
with chlamydia I mean that's not what we
want to do either so if you want to
effectively make the argument make the
case for abstinence you have to make a
moral
we're talking about respect of the human
person
the proper ordering of sexual
relationships proper context if you're
going to give someone give yourself to
someone you should only do that in a
context of love and devotion and all now
that you know all of that is good all
that's true but that is a moral a very
moral thing and I simply don't trust a
health teacher to effectively
communicate that so yeah with my kids
you can leave that to me I will handle
that I don't need you doing it and no I
don't want schools to throw sexual
morality out the window either and say
oh yeah well everyone's having sex so
don't worry about it here's a condom no
see what's wrong what part of this does
the school system struggle to understand
it it's none of your business
okay well the kids attitudes about sex
you know their approach to it the way
families deal with it none of that is
your business why would you think that
it is just because the kid is sitting in
your classroom doesn't make it all the
sudden your business so let's just leave
it alone and and then I know the answer
is gonna be well well yeah but but but
parents don't talk about it and well you
know parents should talk about it with
their kids but if they don't that's
unfortunate but that doesn't give you
carte blanche just like you can't just
walk up to a kid on the playground and
say hey kid I'm sure I'm sure your
parents aren't talking about sex so so
here let me tell you a few things if you
do that you'll be arrested as a sex
offender right all right let's see okay
I have to show you this because I just I
just have to so brace yourself
I'm not gonna give any not gonna give
you any setup just watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
okay first of all don't swaddle your
baby like that you he will die
don't don't tie your baby inside of a
pillowcase and roll him around on the
ground
second any man who chooses to be
swaddled as a form of therapy should
indeed be swaddled and then should be
stuffed into a cannon and shot into the
Sun with all due respect nothing
personal I just think it would be best
for everyone involved all right um this
is from Fox News it says Hofstra
University student activists are calling
for the removal of a statue of Thomas
Jefferson from campus near New York City
because they say that the third American
president represents racism and slavery
so this this statue of Jefferson has
already been defaced in multiple times
and now they want to get it torn down
the only thing I'll say about this is
that you know I am opposed to tearing
down Confederate statues I've said that
many times and I think that one leads to
the other it's not a coincidence that we
started with Confederate statues then we
moved on to this but this is really sort
of a whole different ballgame because at
least with the Confederate statues
although I oppose tearing them down
there was an I don't think it's a very
good argument that but the argument that
was made in favor of tearing them down
was that well you know it's it's not
just that these guys had personal flaws
it's that they were fighting for slavery
and that's what the war was about and so
we should there's no reason why she we
should make an effort to honor them for
that well I think that's a very
reductive and simplistic way of looking
at the Civil War it was a much more
complicated thing than that
and certainly the personal motivations
of the people that were actually
fighting for the Confederacy many times
had absolutely nothing to do with
slavery at all but you know so at least
there's that argument but if we're
getting into tearing down statues of the
founding fathers well you don't have
that argument well because nobody thinks
that the Revolutionary War was fought so
that the colonists could have slaves
they did have slaves but that's not what
the war was about so now this really is
something where even though these men
these were great men who achieved great
things they had this serious personal
flaw which is that they support a
slavery and so therefore we're just
going to tear down their statues and if
we're doing that then we really are just
basically canceling history if that is
now the litmus test then there are very
very very few historical figures who
would be able to survive it because
almost every great historical figure had
serious flaws and many of them had flaws
in the area of slavery because for
thousands of years of human history
almost nobody was against slavery across
the world all races all genders
ethnicities slavery was everywhere taken
for granted as just a perfectly normal
thing doesn't make it right doesn't mean
that it doesn't it's not a it's not a
full-on excuse for those people but it
does put things into a certain
perspective and it does show that well
okay if we're doing this then you know
we get basically tear down all the
statues because it's got to be a total
now whitewashing of history and I think
that is not only a pointless exercise
but also harmful and absurd all right
let's move on emails cuz I got a lot of
great emails and I won't be able to
answer all of them but I want to give it
some time anyway this is from Aaron hey
ry n it's an interesting spelling there
says hi Matt I love your show and your
religious theology is usually on point
but yesterday you made a serious blunder
about God
allowing people into heaven based on
their capacity to biblically love you
said that if a person is capable of
truly loving their spouse or whomever it
may be but they go to hell how do you
reconcile that with the fact that there
is supposed to be no love in hell
first of all Romans 8:1 through seven it
doesn't matter how loving this person is
if they are not in the spirit of god
through the repentance of heart of heart
and forgiveness of sins through Christ
Jesus their acts of love mean nothing
second Abraham who had yet to see the
Messiah was justified only by his faith
also lot who became as wicked as the
city around him and offered up his own
virgin daughters to be raped was
justified in his faith and saved from
death by God in His mercy faith is the
main point of the Bible well I got to
stop you right there I I don't know if I
agree with your interpretation of the
Old Testament especially I don't think
faith is the main point of the Old
Testament at all actually I think the
main message in the Old Testament is
obedience there really wasn't a question
of faith everybody in Old Testament
times believed in some kind of God there
may be a few mentions in the Old
Testaments a few references to something
like atheism but that wasn't really the
problem back then so everyone just took
it for granted that there was a God for
many gods
the issue was obedience which is why all
throughout the Old Testament God passes
down I mean hundreds and hundreds of
Commandments and laws many of them just
vary minut in particular and and so I
think what was the point of that the
point was obedience was getting the
Israelites his chosen people to obey and
so that's how I would interpret it I
don't know anyway I'm not going to we
won't get sidetracked on that it says
third of course an intellectual
pronunciation of Jesus is God will have
bearing on salvation for God it has
always been about the heart because if
you confess with your heart that Jesus
is Lord and believe in your heart that
raised him from the dead you will be
saved for with the heart one believes
and is justified and with the mouth one
confesses and is saved from faith from
the heart must be present in order for
salvation to take place which leads to
my last point the problem you described
as a loving person being in hell so
you're gonna say okay so if you can't go
to heaven because he never believed in
Jesus then there's still the problem of
a loving person being in hell I would
argue this God is the embodiment and in
Pitta me of love we experience his love
and grace the things which he embodies
here on earth as a part of his mercy and
kindness in our physical forms well we
have the time to accept Jesus as
sacrifice on the cross and be saved
scripture speaks of a circumcision of
the heart which only takes place through
surrender denying Jesus is not surrender
once we have consistently denied Jesus
no matter how weirdly loving we may
appear there is no truly biblical love
to be found within our hearts because we
do not have God's Holy Spirit living
within us therefore no truly biblically
loving person can be found in hell
especially when you consider that hell
is the absence of God's presence so all
good things are absent so love with
within anyone would be absent anyway
because the only reason we experience
love is because of God I do love your
show i watch it every day but this made
me cringe you're a great guy brothers
keeps keep searching for the truth
alright Aaron thanks for the email thank
you for really engaging with my points
and expressing your disagreement in a
non pretentious non insulting way and I
mean that sincerely so I thank you for
that I'm going to skip to the last point
you made I don't want to restate what
I've already said the last two shows but
with your last point I think you really
moved the discussion forward and offered
a new thought on this so I don't want a
straw man you I think what you're saying
here is is you're agreeing with with
with me that someone who really loves
who truly loves you call it biblical
love true love bucola
same thing right a truly loving person
cannot go to hell because then you would
have love and hell hell's the absence of
love so how could it be there it's not
possible so you seem to agree with me
there but you
say that well so my point was if love
can't exist in hell then what about
someone who doesn't consciously accept
Jesus doesn't consciously believe in
Jesus yet does have love where do they
go it seems to me that they couldn't go
to hell they would have to go to heaven
and the way you deal with that is you
say well you can't really love if you
reject Christ the reject Christ is to
essentially reject love and so that's
how you deal with the problem I hope I
summarized you accurately accurately
there well I think there are a couple
problems with your point number one
throughout history I'm sure you would
agree there have been many people
probably hundreds of millions who never
believed in Christ yet did not
consciously reject him because they just
never heard about him so from the year
thirty three until until today there
have been as I said hundreds of millions
of people who just never heard about
Jesus think about everyone who lived in
the Far East or in the West across the
Atlantic in the first few hundred years
of the Christian era they couldn't
possibly believed in Jesus nobody told
them about Jesus right so how could they
have known therefore it can't be said
that they rejected him and remember if
somebody lived in in let's say you know
North America in the year 100 well
that's someone who could not have
possibly ever heard about Jesus Christ
and and that's also someone who they're
in North America because God put them
there that's someone who was born in
North America which means they were born
it means they were created that was an
act of creation a conscious act of
creation by God God saying I'm going to
put this person right here thousands of
miles away with a huge ocean separating
him from the news of Christ so it really
doesn't make sense that God would then
say well I put you here but now I'm
gonna send you to hell because you were
there that that becomes very hard to
believe so so you don't really
count for them you're saying well
someone who denies Christ doesn't have
Christ you couldn't really love that so
none of those people could love millions
of people throughout history incapable
of loving but if you allow for them if
you say well no no well then yeah they
could go to heaven because they did
never heard about it and so we'll make
an exception there well if you do that
then you're admitting a couple of things
you're omitting number one that a person
could go to heaven without consciously
believing in Jesus number two that
therefore they could enter through the
door who is Jesus Christ the way the
truth and life without consciously
knowing it and so if you're accepting
that then it seems that you're you're
not far from my conclusion but okay
let's put those cases to the side for a
minute
let's talk about people in modern
society who have heard about Jesus and
but yet belong to a different religion
well of them it seems like you certainly
are saying that they could not really
love even their own children right well
I just I don't think that there's any
evidence for that I don't think that's
true at all I think that it's really
quite presumptuous and insulting to say
that non-christians can't love their
kids or their spouse now I don't know I
know you don't need it as men so I'm not
attacking you but you have to think how
would you take it if a Muslim said to
you that you can't love your kids
because you're not a Muslim you would
just say well that's absurd what are you
talking about of course I love my kids
so I absolutely believe that
non-christians can love their children
and their spouses and can love anyone
just just as I can remember Jesus says
in scriptures greater love hath no man
than this that a man lay down his life
for his friends well what about a Jew or
a Hindu who lays down his life for his
country or his wife or his kids his
family his friends
Jesus says that is the greatest love the
greatest he didn't say greater love hath
no man than this a Christian lays down
his life for his friends didn't say that
he says a man who lays down his life for
his friends
now how could we say then that not only
is that so if we think about a person of
another religion who lays down their
life let's say for their family Jesus
seems to say that's the greatest love
but what you seem to be saying is not
only is that not the greatest love it's
not even love at all well then what is
it in that case a non-christian it makes
a great personal sacrifice for those he
cares about I mean even if it's not
dying for them which many non-christians
have sacrificed their lives for those
they love many times but a non-christian
who lives a life of self-sacrifice for
those that they care about if that's not
love then what is it
and if that's not love then I don't even
know what love is I don't know even I
don't know how we could even use the
term anymore because I would say that's
the definition of love love is is you
know Aquinas says said that love is
willing the good of the other and of
course the the greatest way to will the
good of the other is to give your life
for the good of the other and so if
someone is willing the good of the other
to the best of their ability and of
their knowledge and you know in the best
way they know how
then I would call that love I read a
story you know I don't want to I'm not
trying to make this an emotional
argument but I do think we should just
when you you know it's easy for us when
we're talking about these issues to just
say oh yeah well Christian does can't
really love and it's easy for us to say
that but let's let's talk about what
we're really saying when we say that so
I read a story a while ago about a
mother in Auschwitz Jewish mother whose
children were being sent to the gas
chamber and she could have been selected
for because she was young enough and
healthy enough she could've been
selected for labor and maybe survived
but she chose to go to the gas chamber
with her kids so that she could comfort
them in their last moments and she
decided that her kids were going to have
several moments of terror and pain and
suffering and she would rather give up
her entire the rest of the rest of her
entire life she'd rather give it up just
so that she could comfort her children
in those moments so are you gonna tell
me that this mother who went to the gas
chamber with her child and comfort her
child until the end was then sent to
hell for all eternity they're gonna tell
me that mother didn't love her child if
that's not love I mean let me tell you
something if that's not love then I
don't love anyone I have no love and I
doubt you do either because if that's
not love I mean if that doesn't qualify
then it's hopeless for all of us no I
would say that that is the greatest love
and I think that's what Jesus said so
when I read the Gospels and I read about
the Lord who said there is no greater
love than self-sacrifice I just don't
see a Lord who sends a woman to hell
forever who gave up her life for a child
because she believed the wrong thing I
don't see him and it really is as simple
as that for me but you know I that's a I
understand the attempt at a you know I
appreciate you're trying to deal with
with the issue and and come up with some
sort of solution all right this is from
Maria says Matt I have appreciated your
discussion about the question of whether
love can exist in hell I think the
answer is no it cannot but I also don't
think that anyone who figured out how to
love on earth will necessarily go to
heaven let me explain why if a person
who does not know Christ manages to love
in life that doesn't mean he will carry
that with him into the afterlife it
could be that he goes to hell but his
love doesn't come with him if that makes
sense so rather than his love carrying
him into heaven it could be that he goes
to hell without it no goodness can exist
in hell but
bad people have a little goodness in
them okay Marie that's an interesting
thought I'm not sure if it works though
first of all what does it really mean
for a person to leave their love behind
does God conduct some sort of like
posthumous spiritual surgery separating
them from their love so they can leave
that and go and be damned and if those
kinds of adjustments are being made why
wouldn't God take take the good and
throw out the bad and that's what CS
Lewis was talking about in the great
divorce that got whatever a little bit
of good is there whatever a little bit
of love God will take that fan those
flames turning it turn it into a great
fire good kind of fire that's me makes
sense it makes less sense if God is
seizing onto the bad stuff and throwing
out the good so that the bad can be
chucked into hell that if we're making
posthumous adjustments of any kind so
that a person can fit one place on the
other it just makes more sense that it
would go north rather than south but the
bigger problem is a logical one I think
is that so let's say that I go to hell I
hate to make myself the example here but
so just a you know frame it here let's
say that I got forbid I'm the unlucky
guy here okay well I can't my love for
my children can't come with me my love
for my wife can't come with me my love
for my family for everything everything
that I love none of that can come all of
that is shed like snakeskin I guess and
then whatever whatever other meager good
parts of me there's not a lot but
whatever's there that all goes too and
then the rest is is sent to hell well
then what exactly is in hell is that
even still me it can it even be said at
that point that I am in hell mean who is
that person is that what I even
recognize that person as being me what I
then it would I would I have any memory
of anything you've just taken the most
essential aspects of my being and Chuck
them and then what so what the heck is
down there in hell and if that thing
down there in hell is hardly even a
conscious being then what's the point of
Hell anymore now see
like you're getting into annihilationism
we're really the the person who doesn't
go to heaven is essentially just
annihilated I don't believe that but
that seems to me more of what you're
talking about but if I am conscious of
myself if I am a conscious self in hell
then but then again how how could I
remain a conscious self after these most
crucial aspects of myself have what been
taken it's so I just there there are
some logical issues there that I can't
quite get around alright let me just do
one more let's see a couple good
responses from teachers okay this is
from Bob and Michelle two people teaming
up on an email says Matt in regards to
your question about gender-based
participation in classes school
classrooms says my wife and I are both
teachers our combined experience covers
just over 30 years of grade school high
school college we also both run a
tutoring business and see many many
students at varying ages and nearly
every imaginable topic and subject
matter the following are our collective
opinions on the matter during certain
age spans participation will be weighted
toward the boys ages grades eight I
guess ages 8 through 12 while at other
ages the girls 14 through 18 when it
comes to certain subjects geometry
history phys ed boys tend to relate more
and therefore participate / question
more when it comes to other subjects
algebra science sociology girls tend to
relate more and therefore participate in
question more also the specific time of
any particular year can play a small
role for the genders as to their general
motivation and attentiveness however my
wife and I both agree that girls tend to
raise their hands participate in
discussion and turn in work projects etc
or more after some discussion with other
teacher friends over the weekend we
believe that it's probably a three to
two girl - boy ratio hope this is of
some help yeah that is in fact I got a
bunch of I don't have time to get into
them I have to say number tomorrow but I
got a lot of responses from teachers as
I raised the question yesterday of do
boys or girls tend to be more to
participate more and be more
in classroom and a lot of interesting
answers to that but I think we're gonna
cut it off here and do all the rest of
the emails tomorrow thanks for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show a 61 year old woman has just
given birth to her own granddaughter who
was conceived by combining her
daughter's egg with the sperm of her
son's gay lover we will examine modern
love check it out at daily wire com